Вулиця Бучі, всіяна тілами. Щонайменше двадцять загиблих на дорозі й тротуарах.
Деякі зі зв'язаними руками. Українські посадовці звинувачують у вбивствах
цих мирних мешканців російських військових.
А в Кремлі заявляють: кадри - постановочні.
Чергову фейкову атаку влаштували в Бучі Київської області після того,
як звідти вийшли російські військовослужбовці відповідно до їхніх планів
і досягнутих домовленостей. Там через кілька днів влаштували інсценування,
яке розганяють всіма каналами і соцмережами українські представники
і їхні західні покровителі.
Жодних доказів цьому Росія поки не навела. Однак деякі проросійські користувачі соцмереж
стверджують, що знайшли їх. На цьому відео, яке оприлюднили першого квітня,
вгледіли нібито порух руки людини на узбіччі.
Утім, якщо проаналізувати це ж відео в негативній обробці, то можна помітити:
те, що схоже на руку, насправді відрізняється за кольором від тіла.
Ми вивчили версію цього відео у вищій роздільній здатності і з'ясували, що рухомий об'єкт
- це крапля води на лобовому склі. Експерт-криміналіст підтвердив наші доводи.
Це насправді не рух руки, а лише ефект на зображенні від накладання краплі на тіло людини.
Саме відео, роздільна здатність кадрів дозволяють побачити це достатньо чітко.
На цьому ж відео користувачі соцмереж знайшли ще один момент:
нібито в боковому дзеркалі видно, як людина на узбіччі підіймається
і сідає, коли авто минає її. Якщо поглянути уважніше, то можна помітити,
що дзеркало просто спотворює зображення.
Крім того, уряд РФ запевняє, що мертвих тіл на вулицях не було, коли російська армія
залишила Бучу, за їхніми словами, 30 березня.
Але супутникові знімки американської компанії Maxar доводять хибність цієї версії.
Ці фото були зроблені 18 і 19 березня, повідомили в Maxar. І на них уже видно тіла загиблих.
Ось ця ж вулиця Яблунська на Google-картах, вона розташована на півдні Бучі.
Видання New York Times порівняло супутникові знімки з відео, знятими першого і другого квітня.
Тіла залишалися на тих самих місцях протягом усього часу.
Через російську пропаганду чимало людей у світі досі сумніваються в тому, що сталося під Києвом.
Найкращий спосіб перевірити - побачити на власні очі. Ось що розповідає
журналістка DW Александра фон Намен, яка побувала в Бучі.
Російських військових звинувачують у жахливих воєнних злочинах тут, у Бучі.
Очевидці розповідають про масові страти, навмисні вбивства цивільних.
Український уряд закликає міжнародних експертів приїхати сюди й провести розслідування.
Вони сподіваються, що це могло б кардинально змінити реакцію світу на війну.
Це інший район Бучі. Криміналісти забирають з подвір'я тіла шістьох мирних жителів,
яких виявили нещодавно.
За словами поліцейських, люди загинули не від снаряду. Їх застрелили й підпалили.
Є війна, коли військові знищують військових. Коли це люди спеціально навчені,
підготовлені й готові на смерть за певні свої ідеали. То тут розстріли й вбивства цивільних людей.
Попри це трагедія в Бучі викликає суперечки. Ось цей користувач не довіряє світлинам,
тому що на них не видно крові.
Вивчення доказів - справа експертів. Утім, проаналізувавши фото з Бучі,
ми побачили багато калюж на вулицях. У місті кілька разів йшов дощ,
що можна перевірити на ресурсах з прогнозом погоди. Це одне з пояснень відсутності плям крові.
Але Міноборони Росії запевняє, що поки Буча була під контролем російської армії,
"жоден місцевий житель не постраждав від насильницьких дій".
Це твердження суперечить відео, фото й свідченням жителів Бучі.
Сьомого числа його забрали, а восьмого його, виявляється, застрелили.
І знайшли лише коли вони пішли. Вони просто його катували.
Ми знайшли його тіло, в нього були поламані пальці й прострілена голова.
А є такі, що тут у дворах чотирьох людей поховали, там у лісі поховали.
Ми не бачили на власні очі, що відбувалося в Бучі.
Триває розслідування правозахисних організацій.
Що вже відомо напевне: є загиблі цивільні і багато горя.